ogni tanto mi capita di girare sul web e
di vedere cose su di me e magari e
quando vedo certe cose nuovamente il rec
regista tipo adesso perché fino a due
minuti ma io non dovevo registra niente
ho visto una cosa va registro stefano
lepri conosciuto come step di mi manda
un messaggio e mi scrive questo vediamo
che il link mi manda stefano
io sono lei non fa vj per canzone è
consigliato l'utilizzo delle cuffie
guarda anche di un cervello mi saltano
youtuber abbigliamento on point anni
tomeo l'ombrello di storia choir molto
chic cappello ancora più chic zio così
che la moda non so cosa mi devo
aspettare la star aveva ragazzi arriva
troppo arrivato rock tra tutti su con le
mani perché questa è già una hit
grazie per l'epilessia molto gentile
riusciamo più a sbuffo di gente
[Musica]
che mossa era che mossa vera cos'è
gesù cristo
madonna che effetti cosa sto vedendo
lega basta ma perché
certo
guarda detto fiero
andrea diprè ma con un cappello di te
quando ascoltate romanzi e cosa dite
quando ascoltate clay e io sono qua
verterà lively gasco i gatti zio coi
gatti santo gesù questa canzone
diventerà la hit dell'estate 2017
credete di no ma io ci credo perché le
crispy colpe sta facendo e voi mi dite
che io assomiglia adige
ma dove ma cosa ma nessuno di voi mi ha
detto la cosa mi ha detto
[Musica]
ragazzi vi giuro su dio è la cosa più
[__] più [__] che abbia mai visto è un
genio in casa è un genio mante fatemelo
incontrare questo uomo ma poi ma qui
movimento di mano è bellissimo ma cos'è
velisti chi guarda azione hai un futuro
meraviglioso
[Musica]
non farti condizionare dal pregiudizio
degli altri 66 play fa rima anche con
sensei la sindrome di tourette
spiega i suoi problemi ma perché sono lì
qui video memoria i problemi si palesi
durante l'infanzia migliaia
qui erano pieni e anche adesso ma i suoi
tic peggiorano chiaramente vado sembra
che abbia perso la testa
[Musica]
in genere a una disfunzione di questa
particolare area c'era una mancanza di
freni inibitori nei pensieri e nelle
parole ragazzo [__] merda troy e zoccole
sono contento quando mi tira il caf
la sindrome di tourette è un disturbo
biologico va a miscelare del cervello
specialmente il lobo frontale un tic è
definito come el urgenza di fare
qualcosa
un'azione ripetitiva che dopo essere
evitata
[Musica]
e bellissimo e farlo benissimo e parto
da lì e verbali sono talmente gravi che
non può più lavorare e praticamente
confinato in casa
questa è una domanda quanti in video ti
sei scaricato frederick trenker sempre
far quanti quanto ti sei martellato le
vene per cercare tutta sta roba si
visione 6 scaricati 2000 a parte il
fatto il video è geniale ma in italia
solo per questo si scaricano 2000 video
anche un giro al supermercato può
diventare un dramma certi il tipo di
sfondo diceva questo anche un giro al
supermercato può diventare un dramma e
lui è riuscito a beccare l'unica scena
dove riuscì ad una mia vita in un
supermercato dove caso dal bello al
contrario è un dramma tenta di rimediare
con gli amici conosciuti al gruppo di
supporto sociale fermi tutti loro
soffrono della sindrome leggibile ha
visto l'uomo è perfetto per i tour etici
guarda video mi guardi sentiamo
veramente is adattati mentali bellissimo
siete dei disadattati mentali la
sindrome che prende sopravvento scusato
molto spesso chi soffre della sindrome
di tourette viene scambiato per un
malato di mente di questo
cariati ho fatto sul canale dure e
maggiormente anche sociale sono le
ingiurie e gestacci
il texano è rivolto direttamente alle
persone circostanze
[Applauso]
[Musica]
meraviglioso zona anche solo un euro per
lorenzo dai pure a me i soldi per lory
poi gli dico il segno io tranqui
grazie zio donate un euro tutti ha
bisogno di fari cocaina in smer dai muri
l'inizio è bellissimo è mentalmente non
così in realtà in questo momento sono io
non è finita la chimica porcata
dopodiché ragazzi si inserisce la
toccatina in fogli che non ho idea di
quanta cassa in teoria dovevano andarmi
la polverina ne ho bisogno di capite ne
ho bisogno la polverina ne ho bisogno
questo io da piccolo provava a fare
tanti out attack tantissimi sapete
quanti me ne sono venuti e pensa che
mason è studiata per tipo una quindicina
di minuti ma questa era prevedibile
porca questo ho dovuto impararlo la mia
sottogruppo divertito nella mia vita non
sono mai riuscito a fare un cazzo cinese
per completare l'opera ragazzi manca
solo una cosa sì grandissimo funziona ce
l'abbiamo nel culo è percorso da ragazzi
il tappo
oddio no no no no no no no no facendo
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo vita basta va
bene così iscriviti che mi piace
condividere con la censura al 1000 vengo
a tagliare su facebook te la tua nonna
religiosa praticante va bene va bene
ragazzi direi che possiamo
in questo video reaction visti tre è
stato proprio devastante tra tutti e tre
il primo si potrà vedere al talento
degli altri si intravedeva e la poca
pina in fogli però io mi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come se tu sei una visione
assolutamente non mi piace anche va
risolto che cominciò a tutte le
descrizioni cosa che insieme ci vediamo
con il telecomando un doppio eccolo sono
decido che non lo trovo più bei ragazzi
[Musica]